[Music]
hello my name is guillermo moreno-sans
i'm the global scientific director of
chiron life sciences corporation which
is a canadian colombian company with
headquarters in bogota colombia
i have a phd in neuropharmacology my
area of expertise is the pharmacology of
the endocannabinoid system which is a
target for the active molecules present
in cannabis such as thc
tetrahydrocannabinol or cbd cannabidiol
my talk today is going to be about
prescription patterns and clinical
outcomes from a large cohort of chronic
pain patients prescribed with
cannabis-based formulations at serenia
clinic in bogota colombia
the content of this talk has been
accepted for publication at frontiers in
paying research
with the title sex-dependent
prescription spatter and clinical
outcomes associated with the use of two
oral cannabis formulations in the
multimodal management of chronic pain
patients in colombia
i'm going to describe the patient
population on this clinic called serenia
clinic which is
specialized in the treatment of
different ailments especially chronic
pain anxiety
insomnia or depression
with medical cannabis formulations as
you may know the treatment or the usage
of medical cannabis was approved in
colombia in 2017
in the form of oral extracts so the
flower from the flower presentation is
not permitted
and these formulations are
commercialized
under the uh the form of magistral
formulations so they need to be
prescribed for a particular patient
and for a particular ailment
so uh what we did was out of the
patients the patient population visiting
and receiving treatment for um
at-serenia clinic
from the period of may
2020 to september 2020.
we um we first select those patients
that
actually uh reported uh
a prompt questionnaire a patient
reported a patient uh reported outcome
measure questionnaire
aim at capturing the improvement
of the uh of the primary symptom from
the moment they started to take medical
cannabis
out of these patients uh we selected
those that indicated chronic pain as the
main symptom for which or the main
indication for which they will be
treated with medical cannabis
out of those patients we excluded those
that
had certain inconsistencies between the
medical records available at the clinic
and the questionnaire uh
responded by reported by the patient for
a final
clinical cohort population for a final
cohort of
2112
patients that were finally included in
the study
among these patients we can see that we
have a clear
bias towards female 76
of the population were actually female
and 23 percent of the population were
indeed male
uh regarding the age groups we have 67
of these uh uh patients were
younger than 65 years old while
32.3 of them were older than 65 years
old
the access of these patients to the
clinic remember that this is a
specialized clinic
where mainly through three different
four different routes
most of them over 75 percent of them
were derived to the clinic through their
contributive
insurance their social security
uh
3.2 were subsidized by the state
18.9 were uh particular so they were uh
they were self-referred or they were
walking in into the clinic and point one
only point one uh percent of them were
covered were referred by their label or
work insurance
out of uh all these
uh
2112 patients we have 61 of an sp
diagnose according to icd-10 criteria
with anesthesia and specified pain
26 26.5
uh were uh diagnosed with pains from the
muscular skeletal uh system so
lgs in general
uh 8.8
uh were due to neurological disorders
and um we have other patients that did
not uh uh you know follow or were
diagnosed with any of these indications
so out of the uh cannabis based
medicinal products available to
prescribers in serenia as we were saying
um this is one of the strengths of the
study normally typically observational
studies
mix and match a lot of different
products routes of administration
uh docification regimes
so in this case
uh available to prescribers at serenia
clinic we have four
material formulations
one chemotype one or high thc containing
20 milligrams per ml and less than one
milligram per ml of cbd
we have two um we have a chemotype two
uh
medicinal formulation number two
it's a balanced formulation coming from
a
particular variety all of these
oral extras were mono varietal meaning
that they were not mixed from different
varieties but they were extras from a
single variety
the final specification of the product
is 12 milligrams per ml of thc 14
milligrams per ml of cbd and finally we
have two chemotype 3 formulations
one of them is contains 30 milligrams
per ml of cbd with less than 0.2 percent
uh thc and the other one has 100
milligrams per ml cbd with less than 0.2
percent or 2 milligrams per ml thc which
is similar to the concentration and the
composition of the
approved uh medicine epidiolex
here you can see also the major terpenes
in the flowers of these varieties for
which as we were saying these are
mono-varietal extracts from these uh
three
um
chemo bars
and the uh the presentation of the
magistral formulation is a 30 ml glass
bottle with a syringe for
the easier application in milliliters of
the corresponding dose
so out of this prescribed chemotypes we
can see that um
you know off the bot we have the first
striking observation we see that two of
these formulations accumulate over 99
of the prescription so basically the
chemotype one
high thc formulation and the chemotype 3
with 100 milligrams per perimeter
formulation um were
all were almost um
[Music]
non-prescribed to any of these patients
really residual prescription less than
one percent among the two of them and
most patients were prescribed either the
balance
formulation
fm002 almost 40 percent and then um we
see that the the main prescription was
the cbd
30 milligrams per ml formulation fm03
which represented almost 60 percent so
we have this 40 to 60 distribution among
the balanced formulation and the high
cbd 30 milligrams per ml formulation
uh you can see to the right your the
daily intake
again with such a big cohort we were
able to divide this cohort in groups by
duration of treatment so we divided
these participants
in
those that were taking medicinal
cannabis for less than four weeks uh
those that were taking between four and
12 weeks so short time
me time 13 to 26 weeks and long time for
over 26s we can see that
the typical uh docification of medical
cannabis uh is performed by titration
slow titration um of the doses
until the patient um achieves
symptomatic control of their uh of their
ailment
so as you can see expressing milliliters
the volumes of these products that
patients were taking depending on how
long they have been taking uh medication
for as you can see there is not a
plateau of the of um
of the doses that we one could expect
after uh reaching the optimal dosing um
however we see a
steady increase and then after you know
12 to 26 weeks
we have a much
less
steep increase in dosing meaning that we
are slowly reaching that plateau and
that actually patients do not need to
further increase their docification
then another interesting observation
that we see off the bat this is the
distribution between sexes between
female and males of the prescription
of fm02 remember the balance formulation
and fm03
the formulation with 30 milligrams
of cbd less than 0.2 percent thc so we
can see that overall
males were preferentially prescribed
with the balanced formulation less than
40 less than 50
were actually prescribed with the cbd 30
milligrams per ml formulation fm03 while
in the case of females more than 50
percent were prescribed with the cbd
only formulation and then we can see an
interesting trend as we evaluate or
analyze the um
the the period of understanding of the
treatment
and you can see that
while females keep the prescription
over 50 at all times for the cbd
formulation you can see that males
start with over 50
of um prescription on the cbd 30
milligrams per ml
and then after 12 weeks it's almost 12
uh 50
and beyond 12 and 26 weeks we see a
decrease of the ratio between
those per square foot balanced
formulation and those prescribed with
cbd there is two likely explanations to
this uh what we see is that there is a
higher proportion of male switching
chemotypes from their initial cbd 30
percent
to um a balanced formulation that might
be more effective to these patients
and at the same time we see a higher
rate
of uh withdrawal from treatment in those
males
treated with just cbd or maybe also
to the limited efficacy of this
formulation in this type of patients
we
discussed in the in the paper that
although this seems to be striking
because the clinical evidence to support
the use of cbd only formulations on
chronic pain patients is um
is very limited and we we know that thc
is the
cannabinoid that is going to engage with
cv1 receptors and therefore being able
through several mechanisms to palliate
this chronic pain in this type of
patients we see that especially in women
the case is that
patients continue to report benefit from
low doses and i'm saying low in
comparison with the clinical
effective doses of cbd that we have from
the epidiolex clinical trials still
continue to report a benefit in their in
their chronic pain this might be also
associated um others such as stacey
gruver
and other authors have also found
unpublished uh similar observations in
which
cbd formulations might be affecting mood
rather than uh um
the pain perception but this
at the same time at the same time
contributes to an overall improvement of
the health of these patients that might
might you know uh be related to this
report of a benefit in the chronic pain
condition
so those patients reporting a benefit
are the absolute majority as you can see
nine out of 10 patients reported some
degree of um
of improvement
with
less than 10 of patients reporting no
improvement whatsoever
and then you can see also the degree of
improvement in the uh in the graph to
your right as you can see there is a
gaussian distribution centered on the 70
percent um
of improvement so those are on the
y-axis you see the percentage of
patients and on the right on the x-axis
you see the percentage of improvement
that these patients are uh reporting so
again the the uh
for clarity of interpretation we um
represented this um as four degrees of
improvement residual for those
responding zero or ten percent
improvement uh slight improvement for
those responding 20 30 or 40 percent of
improvement
moderate improvement for those reporting
50 60 or 70 percent improvement and
robust improvement for those reporting
80 90 or 100
improvement on their pay on their
chronic pain
as you can see moderate and robust are
related to
a reported benefit higher than 50
percent
and here we have the degree of
improvement by chemotype
and by age group uh so
just talking about
chemotype
fmo2 which is a balanced chemotype or
fm03 which is the cvd predominant
chemotype we have we see very similar
responses
in terms of the degree of improvement
and then dividing by
young adults under 65 or elderly over 65
we couldn't find any significant
differences
if any you might see that
or seems like medical cannabis works or
these these elderly patients are
reporting
slightly less benefits we can see that
there is a little more increase on this
residual plus slide improvement
both for both chemotypes but again these
differences are
not statistically significant
when we look at the degree of
improvement by sex chemotype and
treatment duration we can see a clear
trend
on uh those patients that are treated
for under four weeks uh there is a much
higher rapport of residual and slight
improvement and after uh you know the
treatment or the um the dose in the
ideal dose has been reached the patient
has get used to the um
side effects of the treatment uh their
patients are starting to report a more
stronger more robust benefit you can see
the robust uh fraction on the dark
side of the column on the top but when
we add um robust
plus uh
let's moderate
uh we see how there's this trend towards
a
much better improvement
as the treatment goes uh goes by so
basically after uh four to twelve weeks
uh we're reaching maximum uh levels of
uh of um
of uh benefit uh at treating this uh
chronic pain at these patients
again uh uh besides the efficacy of the
treatment at um
benefiting this control of chronic pain
we also ask patients to report a series
of um of side effects that could be
associated to the treatment so uh
occurring of adverse side effects this
is the total amount of patients this is
the 212th
cohort um 70
almost i mean more than 70
71.7 percent of patients describe um
no side effects at all
the most frequent side effects with
somnolence we'll see a breakdown now by
sex and chemotype as well
followed by dizziness with eight percent
dry mouth at 4.26 percent and other
minor side effects we're going to see a
table
right now
so uh maybe you cannot see in detail uh
please i will refer you to uh the open
access publication
that uh captures all and reports all
these data as you can see
uh or as we described in the major side
effects are going to be sunlines
dizziness dry mouth
and then
we have others such as headache or
anxiety
but already appear as very very minor
rare cases i mean interestingly i mean
obviously we have more cns related side
effects with the chemotype um
oo2 with the chemotype with the balanced
chemotype the formulation that contains
thc
however i mean we still see um you know
side effects such as somnolence or
dizziness related to
very low doses of cbd
uh we're gonna see a breakdown
of that immediately as you can see in
here we have up to 30 percent of
patients
especially females reporting
somnolence associated with the
formulation that contains thc even if it
is balanced formulation we know that cbd
by contract some of these side effects
more obvious neurological side effects
caused by thc
but you can see that the female
population uh both under four weeks and
up to 12 weeks describes a huge
incidence of um compared to the rest of
side effects of course incidence of
sunlight
specifically females we don't see that
on on males but at the same time we see
how the incidence of sunless is reduced
after these 12 weeks of um
of uh of treatment
on the other side we see that the rest
of the of the side effects there's not a
clear marked difference
between uh males and females
and also between uh uh
the thc containing formula on the cbd
only formulation uh you can see that
obviously
they're reduced within time so i mean as
others have described
this type of side effects are mild and
do not interfere with regular day life
and um they're also
and they tend to reduce as the patient
optimizes the dose and gets used to
these side effects
so in conclusion we can say that first
both males and females reported more
significant benefits after the initial
four weeks once an optimal dose in the
gene was reached and that this period
was also associated with the highest
incident of adverse side effects
remember in particular somnolence for
the female participants it is therefore
extremely important for both patients
and prescribing physicians to persist
with therapy through this initial dosing
adjustment phase as we were seeing as we
were saying i will discuss in the paper
this seems to be a trend by several
clinicians in many different
jurisdictions such as canada
israel the uk
in which uh
physicians
tend to start patients with cbd only
formulations just because it's safer
from a side effect
point of view however as we have seen
particularly male population this might
also be related with withdrawal from
treatment due to the lack of effect of
these formulations especially for
chronic pain so establishing treatment
goals during the initial consultation
can be very helpful to provide a
structure to this process of going
through the first four weeks of
treatment to achieve
you know the most benefit from medical
cannabis treatment
secondly
most observational and experimental
studies investigating the efficacy of
cannabis based medicinal products for
pain management are of relatively short
duration generally under four weeks our
results indicate that the perceived
effectiveness report by patients was
maintained on the short
4-12 weeks intermediate 12 to 26 weeks
and long-term over 26-week
duration of treatment
which is well aligned with the results
from randomized clinical trials using
naviximos which as you know it's a
formula it's an ethanolic extract
for sublingual administration that
contains
equivalent concentrations of thc and cbd
so uh as we were saying randomized
clinical trials using navigables uh in
ms patients in multiple sclerosis
patients show sustained improvements in
pain and other symptoms for more than 12
weeks without developing tolerance
finally
as i will say take away results from
this research we
see that nine out of 10 participants
reported some degree of improvement in
the control of their chronic pain
symptoms
7 out of 10 participants reported an
improvement equal or larger than 50
since starting the treatment with
cannabis-based medicinal products
and 7 out of 10 participants did not
report any side effect
treatment with medicinal cannabis was
generally well tolerated no serious
adverse events occurring and as
suspected the thc containing formulation
was accompanied by a significantly
higher prevalence of central nervous
system related side effects such as some
knowledge especially in the female
cohort and dizziness we were more
prominent in the first four week of
treatment as we were saying also these
side effects appear to be transient um
reducing their impact on the uh on
medication as the treatment goes up
so uh this was my time uh thank you very
much for uh attending um this seminar
uh i remain at your disposal for any
further questions that you might have
you can reach me on my email g moreno
g-m-o-r-e-n-o
at chiron k-h-i-r-o-n
dot c-a
uh thank you very much to labruts for
giving us this opportunity to present
our results and
again you can look up for the
publication of these results in the
journal frontiers in pain research thank
you very much for your attention
you